after you've defined the content formula
that works for you
you started optimizing your content you
want to start pushing out content
regularly and i think charlie demilio is
the best example of someone who has
created a content formula
and then just started testing and
iterating she didn't come up with the
dance moves that she posts on her tik
tok on her own
she found really prominent dancing tic
tackers
in the space started copying their dance
moves maybe making them her own a little
bit but because she's not coming up with
those ideas on her own
she's able to post two to three videos a
day and constantly show up in the feed
the thing with tik tok is and this is
actually just with any social platform
in general
you are a video in a feed right people
are going to be scrolling through
they're going to forget about you as
soon as they're done watching that video
so you want to make sure that you're
constantly pushing out content so you're
staying top of mind for the people that
are
that are watching the platform